in India the number of confirmed
coronavirus infections has now topped
600,000 but the Indian government is
striking back of critics who say it
hasn't done enough to fight the pandemic
it has introduced a revamped strategy to
curb the spread of the virus DWS Munir
Chaudhary brings us this report from the
worst-hit City Delhi a massive
door-to-door survey exercise has been
launched in Delhi for its entire
population of about 20 million residents
the state government is aiming to record
the health details of each and every
household to deal with the spread of
coronavirus the move has come after
weeks of scrambling for measures by both
the state and the national government to
avoid a major healthcare disaster in the
capital city which has now become the
worst hit in the country even the
government is not you know sure what
will work out and what will not work out
so I'm little scared but we can't lose
earlier we could step out a little at
least to buy essentials and groceries
but now we're worried that if we step
out at all we may get infected as part
of its revamped strategy to handle the
spread of cases the Delhi government is
taking a range of measures they include
increased testing and contact tracing
antibody testing developing a plasma
bank and providing oximeters to Corbitt
patients the government simultaneously
is trying to wrap up its healthcare
infrastructure the daily testing for
Corbett 19 has increased significantly
the state government says that it is now
conducting 20000 tests every day
apart from plans to start rapid antigen
testing which allows for faster
diagnosis of samples regular testing
camps are also being set up
especially in coronavirus hotspots known
as containment zones Sangam Behar one of
Delhi's largest and most crowded
informal settlements has several
containment zones the new testing camps
there have already started making a
difference during the past week testing
has increased many positive cases are
getting detected earlier the testing
wasn't so regular now it's daily
some 200 people are tested at each camp
here daily anybody testing positive is
immediately taken to makeshift
quarantine centers crucial for those
we're home isolation is not an option
the Delhi government has projected that
the number of cases in the capital may
rise up to half a million by the end of
July to handle such a case load some
spacious venues in the city are also
being converted into Corbett care
facilities this ashram is being prepared
to become one of the world's largest
Corbett care centers essentially an
isolation facility it has a capacity of
10,000 beds most of which are made of
prefabricated cardboard material once
opened it will provide round-the-clock
medical supervision for mild and
moderate cases there is pressure on the
general care healthcare system it is a
new disease one that we were not fully
equipped to deal with when it began and
it became a pandemic and we have to
supplement the general health care
systems even though lockdown
restrictions have been eased to some
extent in Delhi there is still much
confusion and anxiety amongst its
residents as the capital continues to
formulate and implement new strategies
it has a tough task ahead of itself as
the challenge of coronavirus has now
turned into a crisis and let's get more
I am joined now by our correspondent in
Delhi Munira Chow Deary who submitted
that report for us you looked at these
measures taken by the government in
order to contain the virus yet we're
seeing a spike in daily cases does it
mean the measures have failed well one
big reason that the spike in the number
of cases we is being attributed to if
the relaxation in the lockdown rules the
life is returning back to normalcy a lot
of economic activities have resumed
markets have opened up and Delhi being a
very densely populated city this kind of
transmission when a lot of people do
resume their daily work is quite
possible but on another side of the
story is also that after this became
evident that Delhi is seeing a lot of
cases the test
increase now jelly is testing a lot more
than a lot of other cities which are
still testing around seven or eight
thousand people per day Delhi is now
testing twenty thousand about so because
of this increased testing more and more
cases are being detected now so we are
seeing a lot of numbers coming forward
because of increased testing as well are
those tests easily accessible to
everyone who needs them who wants them
well now the testing facilities have
increased you can go and get tested in
hospitals and the bottle trees but you
do need to be sure about your symptoms
you do need a doctor's prescription
because at the moment only high risk
category people and people who are
showing certain symptoms are being
encouraged to go and get tested and in
of the containment areas as we saw in my
report in informal settlements which are
crowded the government is organizing
these regular testing camps where about
100 or 200 people are getting tested
every day and the test being used are
rapid antigen tests which are showing
results in about 15 to 20 minutes so
positive cases are quickly being either
put in isolation in home or taken to
quarantine centers tell us a little bit
more about those containment areas that
you reported on for the infected what is
what is the state of social stigma
surrounding that do people feel
stigmatized if they feel comfortable
going there well the definition of term
containment zone has been tweet a little
in the past couple of months but
essentially means an area where cases
have been detected and it's for the
government it's important to demarcate
these areas because to map local
transmission and to even prevent local
transmission so movement is restricted
not those many activities are allowed as
in other areas and people do understand
the importance of these zones but people
who do feel a little stigma are those
you know are outside whose homes for and
trying posters are being pasted those
who are coming out positive in commit
and what being put under home isolation
so certain posters are being put outside
their homes which basically declared to
what time they're supposed to be in
quarantine they feel a little stigma
coming from there but the government
feels these posters are important
because it gives them a sense of urgency
and responsibility
many are Chowdhury in telly thank you